MANO MARKS: Hi, everyone.
Thanks for coming.
Whoa, that's a little echo-y.
Can we decrease that?
OK.
Hi, I'm Mano Marks.
I'm here with Josh Livni, my
colleague on the Google Geo
Developer Relations team, and
Brian Flood, who is going to
be talking to you
about Arc2Earth.
And we are going to be talking
to you about GIS, Geographic
Information Systems, and how you
can use Google Earth and
Google Maps working with GIS.
So you all know, I'm guessing,
you're all here, you're
probably the hard-core Geo geeks
from this conference.
You all know a lot about Google
and Google Geo and what
Google Geo is good for.
And a lot of what Google Geo
is good for is visualizing
geographic data.
And I'm going to run through--
you've seen all these
statistics before, I'm
sure, but we have--
Google Maps is now on over
600,000 websites.
We have over 800 million
downloads of Google Earth, and
there are over a billion KML,
files, which is a Keyhole
Markup Language that was
originally designed for Google
Earth and is now an open
standard, over a billion KML
files on the web.
The Google Map's API is
the most used mashup
platform in the world.
So that's just a bunch of stuff
that you already know.
You see Google Maps.
You see Google Earth
everywhere, right?
But most of what people do with
Google Maps and KML is
they're showing a point
or a set of points.
And there's a whole other
world which Google Geo
actually does interact with.
And we're going to talk to you
today about some of both the
lesser-known aspects of
different parts of our APIs
and also about some exciting
new upcoming projects.
So this is the list, and I
really dislike agenda slides,
so this is the last time you'll
see this, but we will
let you know where you are
throughout the talk.
But we're going to be talking
a little bit about Google
Earth, Google Maps, As I said,
some new upcoming stuff, some
Fusion Tables, and then we're
going to talk about some
integration examples using open
source libraries really
briefly, and then Brian is going
to show you some really
interesting, real-world examples
of using Google's
technology to interact with
high-end GIS systems.
OK, so let's get started.
And I like to start with
this because this
is kind of the basic.
Like if you ask anybody at a
party if they know about
Google Earth, and they're
going to know
about Google Earth.
Let's try it right now.
How many of you have
used Google Earth?
All right.
How many of you knew that Google
Earth has a server
component to it?
OK, almost everybody.
Of course, for this class--
for this class!
For this workshop, for this
group-- students.
So one of the key components
that we have for enterprise
interactions with Google Earth
is this Google Earth server
that we've had for a
number of years.
And what it does is it fuses
together data from a lot of
different geographic data
formats and pushes it out into
your own private globe.
And one to the key things that
you may not know about, and
this is going to be the extent
of my talking about Google
Earth, actually, today, is this
product here, or actually
what this represents, which
is a portable globe.
So this right here, this is a
portable Google Earth globe.
So those people who have the
Google Earth server can create
these kind of applications
to be used entirely
offline in the field.
So let me describe this
for a moment.
This is $150 piece
of hardware.
It's a physical--
this is an Ubuntu server.
There's an SD card there, 16
gigabytes, and it's got vector
and imagery data on it.
Now, use that in companion with
a Google Earth client--
so this is the Google Earth
enterprise client--
and you'll see right
over here in the
left panel these layers.
Those are entirely customized,
right?
So if you're used to Google
Earth, you're used to seeing
our default layers there.
You'll see a lot of these
start with JP.
This was data that was actually
sent to Japan for use
after the earthquake, where they
had portable generators
in local areas, but they didn't
have internet access so
that they could access
information on servers.
So they shipped servers.
We shipped servers from Mountain
View to that area so
that they could use them
for disaster response.
And just to give a quick little
demo of that, you can
see here that--
where's Japan?
Going into Japan, as we get
closer, you'll see there's
actual vector data.
There's roads that are drawn,
road and boundaries drawn
within Japan that you
then have to.
So let's say major
arterial roads.
So this is just one example
of using the server.
Oh, and I had to switch because
I switched off so I no
longer have this direct
connection to the server.
But basically, I
can draw roads.
I can use that imagery.
If you go to Japan right now,
you'll see that's not the
actual imagery.
And you can connect to it using
also the Google Earth
plugin, which gives
you another direct
connection to that.
So anybody who's got the plugin
installed and the
correct authentication details
can connect into
your server as well.
So this is a really
interesting--
and I think not widely known
outside the enterprise
community--
way to use Google Earth.
So Google Earth server using
a portable globe.
As I said, this costs $150.
Google Earth server costs a
little bit more than that, but
it allows you to do some
really powerful things.
OK, so the next thing I'm going
to talk about are some
of the features of the Google
Maps API that allow you to do
GIS-like operations.
So how many of you know what a
projection is what I'm talking
about maps?
OK, awesome.
So for those of you who are on
video, I'll just briefly
describe it.
Imagine you have a globe,
say, the Earth.
Imagine that globe is actually
like an orange.
You take the orange and you peel
the orange and then you
flatten the peel out.
That's a two-dimensional
representation of your 3D globe.
And that's essentially
what you have to
do for a map, right?
A two-dimensional map is a
two-dimensional representation
of a 3D object, so there's a lot
of math that's involved in
that, and there's different
choices that you can make.
Now, the default projection
is called the Mercator
projection.
And I'm going to give you an
example of some of the
differences.
So imagine I'm flying from San
Francisco to Paris, and I'm
going to roughly click
on where Paris and
San Francisco are.
You'll see I've created two
different lines here.
The red line, or this line that
goes straight across the
map, is the line that you would
naturally draw if you
thought that you could simply
draw a line and it would
connect the two closest
points together.
The other line is a
great circle line.
That great circle line is the
actual shortest path between
San Francisco and Paris,
or roughly here.
Anybody whose flown
internationally knows that
when you want to fly over--
you have to fly over Greenland
to get to Europe.
OK, so let's take a look
at the code for this.
The code for this is actually
fairly simple.
We implemented a new library
system in the Maps API, so
that if you don't want to load
specific portions of the code
for the Google Maps API, these
newer features, you want to
keep your higher performance
applications loading as little
code as possible, then
you don't have to.
But it would give you the option
of loading them in.
So you see this parameter
libraries=geometry is in this
geometry library that allows you
to do these calculations.
And then you'll see all I did
here was in creating this
polyline, I added this option
geodesic true, passed in that
option to this polyline that
I'm creating and set that
polyline onto the map.
So very simple to create
geodesic lines on a map.
So the code for this
other kind of a--
for projections is a little bit
more complex, but I wanted
to show you an example here.
This is a Gall-Peters
projection, and this is using
some tiles that we generated
directly for this.
The idea here is you're showing
a different kind of
projection using the map's API,
and then you're telling
them the map's API
how to map points
between the two locations.
So this is what it would look
like in standard Mercator.
This is what it looks
like Gall-Peters.
And you'll see that Gall-Peters
has a fidelity of
area rather than angle here.
That means that you get a much
better sense of the actual
size of things.
So you see, for instance, Africa
is huge compared to
Greenland, whereas on a Mercator
map, they would look
to be roughly the same size.
You all know about projections
probably quite a bit so I'm
going to not go too much
into detail on that.
But let me just show you a
little bit of the code here.
It's actually fairly--
it's a little involved.
We basically provide you with a
projections interface, which
you have to implement to tell
Google Maps how to map from
what we called world points to
latitude and longitude, and
then you have assign tiles to
match those coordinates.
So is this is just one of the
methods that you have to
implement, which is
point to lat long.
You also have to do
lat long to point.
So the docs on this are really
pretty clear, easy to use.
I'm not going to go too much
more into the details, but
just to show you that we
do have these features.
So these are the major
features of
the geometry library.
We also have some encoding,
polyline encoding and decoding
methods that are in there that
you can use to make the
definitions of your polylines
much shorter.
And then we give you things in
the geometry, the spherical
library, to compute area,
distance, that sort of thing.
And then as I mentioned before
for the projection, we have
these two methods
that you have to
implement on top of the--
when you implement
that interface.
OK, I'm going to switch over to
Josh right now, and Josh is
going to talk to you about
Fusion Tables.
JOSH LIVNI: Thanks, Mano.
Hi, everybody.
So you can see we've come quite
a long way from putting
points on a map or basic
visualization that people
commonly think of Google
Maps or Google Earth.
And both of those, Maps and
Earth, they've been around a
long time, five years or more.
The stuff I want to talk to you
today about are much more
recent developments.
So Fusion Tables, it's the first
year at Google IO that
we're talking about it, and I'm
going to also talk about
some as yet unlaunched things.
So there's been a couple
other talks that have
covered Fusion Tables.
How many of you consider
yourselves very familiar with
Fusion Tables at this point?
OK, so that's good.
About half or so.
I'm going to go into not a lot
of detail on what season
Fusion Tables is, but I'll give
a very brief overview,
and I'm going to focus on some
of the kind of spatial queries
that we can do there
are more GIS like.
So the first thing that I like
to just show off is, hey, we
can have a map here, and this
is a cool map showing 2010
census data put together by John
Keefe at WNYC, where we
can have a lot of different
polygons and some nice
interactive info windows.
And this is the kind of map that
a lot of people want to
make, a core plot color map,
tons of complex polygons.
Very difficult to do previously
without sort of
needing to create your own
tiles, have a rendering
library of your own on your
server, because the Maps API
can't really handle
this number for
vertices all at once.
The browser will keel over.
So Fusion Tables is a great
way to put a bunch of data
into our infrastructure and
then render it on a map.
That's one way of thinking about
it, although it does
quite a bit more.
So let's go on to the API, which
is why we're here as
developers.
It has a sequel-like API, which
means if you're familiar
with using databases, My Sequel,
Postgres and others,
this will be a familiar way of
interacting with the data in
Fusion Tables.
So Fusion Tables is
a set of tables.
For those of you who aren't
familiar, I'll just give a
really quick link here.
What I've done is uploaded a
table of restaurant data that
I downloaded from the city
of San Francisco.
It kind of looks like a
spreadsheet, and it has an
address field here.
And the address field, we're
going to automatically geocode
when you upload a table like
this so that you can then
visualize it in a variety of
different options, including a
map, which I'll get into
in a little bit.
So if I was to use the API to do
a basic select statement, I
could say select the name, which
was one of the columns
in my table from the table ID,
which is an ID you can get by
looking at the URL of your
Fusion Table or some other
ways, and just give me back
five of them, and I'll get
back some information that
looks like this.
I'll just give you a really
quick example in the browser
so you can see it
actually works.
This'll look better if
you can see the URL.
This is limit 15.
If I said limit 150, I'd I get
back some more, and it's
pretty snappy.
So let's move on to some of
the spatial stuff that's a
little bit more GIS like.
A couple of really popular
things people like to do
include what's the closest
things around me?
And so the way that we've
implemented this is using this
order-by-distance idea.
So given a location, so give
me everything that you can.
Select some subset of things.
Order it by the distance from
the location that I give.
So in this case, I've given the
location of where we are,
and say give me back
the closest five.
And the best way to show this
kind of thing is on a map.
I've got some demo links here
so that in the future people
watching a video or yourselves
can get the slides and click
on these for the code.
But here's a map of all
the restaurants,
quite a lot of points.
I should emphasize that all of
these spatial queries also
work with polygons and lines,
not just points, although
that's the demo here.
So down at the bottom left, I
have a little number you can
barely see.
It says 50.
And if I click on the map,
you'll see select statement,
as what happened on my click
handler, which is select
address from the table, order
by the distance, limit 50.
And you can see if I click over
here, it's pretty clustered.
If I click over here in San
Francisco, it tends to be a
little bit less so.
And again, it's pretty quick.
So if I select the nearest
500, we can see we get a
really fast response.
So Fusion Tables lets you
do that kind of query.
Oftentimes, you might just
select the nearest one if
you're looking for the closest
zip code or what have you, but
a great way to be able to
do these types of basic
operations.
Another very common operation is
your spatial intersection.
And currently, we support
circles and bounding boxes.
So here's the syntax for
providing a circle and
intersecting it within this
case your geometry column,
which is the address, which
is then geocoded
automatically for you.
And I'll show you what that
looks like on a map.
We'll go ahead and give a radius
of 1,000 up here, and
I'll click.
And within this radius, we can
see we get a few points back.
We get a few more over here.
And here's the select statement
down at the bottom.
So over on the right, I'm not
showing all of the restaurants
that have been returned.
I'm actually showing a grouping
of these restaurants,
which is pretty neat.
You might imagine you want to
do an intersection, and then
get some statistical information
or some other type
of query on the result.
And so I'll just show
you how I did this.
We can see that if we're
downtown here, and say we go
within 2,000 meters, a couple
of kilometers, we've got--
I don't know--
1,500 restaurants, 160
bars, et cetera.
That's kind of interesting
information.
So I'll show you quickly how I
did this, because I like it
when, instead of just using the
basic features, folks also
start to interact with the
Fusion Tables API to get more
information out.
Some of the other sessions
showed how you can have nice
charts in your info
windows using the
charts API and so forth.
In this case, the second piece
of code is this group-by
bottom line, grouping by
description, and you can see
my select statement has
changed subtly.
So I'm selecting account and
the description and then
grouping by the description,
and that gives me back that
kind of aggregate stats on
the results that I had.
So I find this kind of stuff a
really nice addition to the
side of you map, depending
on your application.
So that's a few features of
Fusion Tables that weren't
covered in some of the other
sessions in too much depth,
and I hope that you guys take
advantage of all the other
things that it offers like the
styling APIs that were
announced and so on and so
forth, but also some of these
more rich spatial features.
So the next item here is
Google Earth Builder.
How many do you have heard
of Google Earth Builder?
OK, so announced just a few
weeks ago at the Where 2.0
Conference, that is
not yet launched.
It'll be out in July, and I
just want to give a really
quick preview to give some of
the vision of where we're
aiming at here.
So a very common problem first
in medium and large-sized
organizations is how do you
manage all of your spatial
data and give people quick and
easy access to it, allow
people to quickly publish and
easily share maps either
within the organizations
or externally?
So one of the main features is
you can upload the data to our
infrastructure.
That's important.
And as you upload it, you can
provide various things.
So, for example, if you provide
some attribution as
part of the metadata, that
attribution will be
automatically baked into the
tiles, whether it's in Google
Earth or Google Maps,
that we publish out.
You can set up tags for
easy searching.
You can easily look over the
data that you have using the
kind of search that we try to be
good at and easily share it
just like it was a Google doc
amongst people within your
organization or externally and
set these robust permissions
to make sure that the
appropriate people are
authenticated, or if you're
sharing publicly, that they
can access as well.
And of course you can do some
basic map creation.
You can set nice style templates
and apply them to
your data, label your data, and
then publish it out in a
variety of formats, whether it's
to Maps or Earth, kind of
using the free Earth API plugin,
or if you're going a
little more secure route, the
Earth Enterprise client that
we saw earlier, and also coming
up on Android, Earth
for Android.
So a couple of really,
really fast demos in
the interest of time.
I'm not going to go
too much into it.
If you're interested, you can
search for Google Earth
Builder, and we have a longer
video online that shows up
some more features.
But just very, very quickly,
first thing you'll see is, as
you log in for your
organization, kind of a
dashboard, giving you a
real-time view, which is very,
very cool, of who's using your
maps, and you'll be able to
dive into this more deeply
down the line.
Please keep in mind this is
unlaunched, and the UI is
still going to go through some
iterations before it comes out
for everyone's use.
But this is just the idea that
it is important for you be
able to see who's looking
at your data and how.
We have some of the things
I talked about, the
attribution, the ACLs.
Let's go ahead and look
at some data.
So if we have a bunch of data,
in this case, I'm going to
search for my digital
ortho quads.
I can see we have a few.
Maybe I'll search for deer
because I noticed this was a
deer lodge.
I see we have some topo maps and
some digital ortho quads,
some raster data that's
been uploaded.
And as you upload it, it's been
processed using the same
sort of workflow that we use
to ingest the data that we
then publish out to
Google Earth.
So you get all of the same nice
ingestion workflow, where
we'll take your data, put it
into what we call layers if
you're putting a bunch
of layers together.
Let's look at our deer lodge
layer made up of these topos,
and then take a quick preview.
And if we're lucky, the Earth
API should automatically
connect in an authenticated way
to Earth Builder in the
background and show you this
data, which has been mosaicked
and kind of blended, again using
the same infrastructure
that we use to ingest data for
our commercial products.
So I'm going to hop
out of this demo--
I think I accidentally did not
open it in a new window so
you'll pardon me here--
and hop over to the next item,
which is Google Earth Engine.
How many of you' have
heard of that?
OK.
So one of the things that's very
tricky in GIS is remote
sensing, or more generically,
image analysis.
It's tricky because it's this
interesting overlap between
scientific communities who
write really complex
algorithms and then at the same
time are trying to manage
sometimes extremely
large data sets.
And so we're trying to solve
this problem-- this is a
google.org product--
using what we're calling Earth
Engine and allowing people to
do near real-time analysis
on very large data sets.
So some of the things I'll just
point out quickly is the
data that you upload will
be kept in this native
projection, which is
super important
for doing image analysis.
You're not warping your data and
getting different results
because of that.
And that you can define
algorithms. We'll launch with
some common algorithms that
people might want to run, but
you'll also be able to have an
API that allows you to define
an algorithm to run
over this data.
And we're also seeding the data
repository ourselves to
start with as much as we can,
reasonably bringing in of the
Landsat and MODIS imagery.
Right now, we're trying to
import the Landsat imagery as
fast as they can get it off
tape, and we have about half
of their petabyte or so of data
online as well as daily
updates on the MODIS imagery on
a whole variety of formats.
And if you check out--
unfortunately, my link's not
showing, but search for Google
Earth Engine at code.google.com,
and you'll
see that you can interact with
all of this data right now, so
it'll give you a hint of
some of what we have.
So I'd like to give a little
bit of context of why you
might be interested in
using Earth Engine.
So that is a satellite view
using the historical imagery
that you would see if you loaded
up Google Earth right
now in Brazil.
And at the bottom left,
you can see the year.
In 1976, it was kind of this
nice, big, green patch.
And if you were to progress
along, you see some forest
patterns changing
a little bit.
And you might ask yourself how
much is actually changing?
It looks like a lot, but what
if I wanted to run this
analysis over an
entire country?
And what if I wanted to
know how much was
being cut per year?
And you had access to all of
this data, which we're hoping
to allow for.
So if you have access to the
Landsat imagery and you have a
lot of it, you can run this type
of analysis using Earth
Engine, and here's the basic
workflow that we use on the
back end just to give you
an idea of how it works.
So we might take this one image,
which is a perhaps a
very large image or set of
images, a collection of images
that we want to run
our analysis over.
And we'll split up into smaller
tiles, and we'll send
these tiles off to separate
machines, and each machine
will run the algorithm that
you've defined over the small
tile in this classic
map-produced algorithm, where
we assemble the final result.
Depending on the algorithm you
run, you might get back an
image or some statistics.
Perhaps you've clipped to a
polygon, and you get the
result back very,
very quickly.
If you're zoomed into an area,
we run in near real time the
analysis just on the area you're
looking at or the area
that you need.
And we're able to do this by
sending it in this sort of
distributed fashion to
our infrastructure.
So that's Google Earth Engine.
This is a really quick
overview of
what we've gone through.
Some of the products have
been around a long time,
overlapping in this larger world
of GIS and moving out of
just pure visualization and
some new things that are
really allowing you to do more
robust analysis and map
publishing and all of the other
things that you see in
many of our products kind of
starting to move more in this
area of GIS.
So to kind of show off what that
actually means for you as
a developer, I'm going to invite
Mano back up to talk
about some of the integration.
MANO MARKS: Thanks, Josh.
I'm going to talk about a
particular set of libraries
that are very commonly
used within
the entire GIS community.
And this set of libraries is
used for doing things like
interacting with GIS data
formats and doing data
conversion.
So this set of libraries is
the GDL/OGR libraries.
GDL stands for geographic data
abstraction library, and I
haven't actually been able to
get anybody to tell me what
OGR stands for yet, so
an interesting--
I'm sure somebody will come up
to the mike and give me their
opinions on that.
But basically, it's a set of
utility libraries for parsing
data, doing data conversion,
doing lots of interaction on a
huge range of geographic
data formats.
And you can do interesting
things like convert data,
reproject it, do data tiling
for raster data.
It's a whole wide set of
things, and most major
software applications that do
these kind of operations rely
on GDL and OGR to do that.
We ourselves use it in some
of our back ends for Earth
Builder and also for Google
Earth Pro for doing data
conversion.
There's just a number of
different ways in which we--
we use these at Google, and
almost all the major
applications use these.
These are open source libraries
under very liberal
licenses, so I'm really
going to encourage you
to check them out.
And I'm going to actually
switch over and we had a
little fire drill beforehand,
so I didn't get a chance to
open up my terminal.
But I'm going to connect to a
server where we set up the
latest version of GDL,
that is, GDL 1.9.
This is actually not available
in the builds,
in the binary downloads.
It's available only in the
nightly build so you have to
actually compile the
source for it.
But the feature that I'm going
to be showing you--
sorry about that--
is a feature that is available
for the first time in GDL.
You can now upload directly to
Google Fusion Tables using the
GDL libraries.
So this is the first time that
cloud data storage feature has
been incorporated within
the GDL libraries.
It's got a very simple mechanism
for doing this.
So what I'm going to do right
now is I'm going to show you a
command line sample here.
So this is a little hard to
read because I have to do
authentication in order to
convert a shape file to Google
Fusion tables.
But what you see here is
I've got OGR to OGR--
which is your data conversion
utility here--
dash f GFT for Google Fusion
Tables, and then this start a
very long string.
You've got those four lines
on the screen there.
That's my auth token
that I got using a
previous command line.
OGR to OGR info, I believe.
And then you'll see the last
line right there is
San_Francisco.shp.
And this is a series of bike
lanes in San Francisco.
I just downloaded this
from the sfdata.gov.
and I run this command line
utility, and it's basically
converting from a shape file to
a Fusion Tables table, and
you see that's done.
It's actually fairly peppy
there, very quick, and I'm
going to refresh my Fusion
Tables list, you'll see there
I have this San Francisco
table.
And I go there, and it's
actually converted the
geometries to KML and
then uploaded them.
I clicked on Map, and
I have this data
directly in Fusion Tables.
So this is available to you
right now in Version 1.9 of
the GDL libraries.
I'm running a little over time,
so I'm going to switch
back to Josh and let
him finish up.
JOSH LIVNI: Thanks, Mano.
So you'll probably have a good
time working with GDL and OGR,
but not all of your end users
will for your applications.
And so I just wanted to quickly
mention before we
bring Brian on stage the kind
of application that we're
hoping you guys might build.
So this is something I put
together in a day called
ShpEscape, which lets you
take a shape file.
How many of you know what
shape files are?
That'd be a good question.
OK, I think we're good then.
Take a shape file and just very,
very easily let the end
user upload a shape file, and
it does basically the same
thing that Mano just showed
off but via WebUI.
And this was built using the
Fusion Tables' API and the
same technologies OGR and
GDL, built on GeoDjango.
So this is open source code in
case you guys want to check it
out, just as kind of an example
of how you might do
this type of thing.
You're welcome to grab it
and build this type of
application.
But much more interesting in
this kind of one-off Stay
application are the really rich
and robust applications
that we're hoping you guys will
put together using all of
our different services and take
advantage of this overlap.
And a really, really great
example of how to do this is
what Brian Flood's put together,
I'll switch over to
his slides here.
BRIAN FLOOD: While Josh is
getting this ready, my name's
Brian Flood.
I work for a company called
Arc2Earth, and we have a piece
of software that is basically a
bridge software between the
Esri ArcGIS world and the
Google Geo world.
So is everyone in the room
familiar with ArcGIS?
Hands up?
So just about everyone.
OK, great.
They clearly are the big name in
the GIS space, and what we
try to do is build applications
to kind of bridge
the two together.
OK, so basically what Arc2Earth
is, it handles
various different aspects of
getting your data out of
ArcGIS and into the Google
Geo properties.
We do KML exports and imports,
map tile cache creation.
We have a new product where we
are bringing Google Map data,
the street data and imagery,
directly into ArcMap.
We do Fusion Table uploads, and
Josh and Mano were talking
about Fusion Table so
I'm going to show
you some demos there.
And then we also have some
planned support for their
really cool new Google Earth
Builder product, which is
coming out.
So basically, I'm just going
to run over this
stuff really quickly.
We actually export KML.
We do some very complex
type of export.
We take all of your symbology.
If you have very large data
sets, we'll break it up into
KML regions for you
automatically.
There's a lot of other bells
and whistles in there.
We also import KML data, and
we're able to get information
out of the pop-up windows
and turn it into real
attributes in ArcGIS.
Map tile caches: basically,
anything that you can display
inside of ArcMap.
This is raster data or any
type of symbology,
TINs or any of those.
You can turn into map tile
caches that can then be
displayed directly over the
top of Google Maps.
To the right there, you can see
another-- this is an open
source application
called MapBox.
We will support those types of
formats so you can take your
map tiles, put them on an iPad
or an Android application and
be disconnected and have
them out in the field.
Data services, as I said, is the
new product we have, and
it's basically taking Google
imagery and bringing
it inside of ArcMap.
Then you can display your data
directly over the top.
Worldwide coverage, and it
automatically freshes as you
move the map around.
Fusion Tables: obviously,
anything you can display and
have inside of ArcMap, you can
point our uploader directly at
it, and it'll take care of it
and use the Fusion Tables API.
So we're not bound by any of
the KML export or import
limits with Fusion Tables right
now, so as large as you
need, it'll ask import it up.
So one of the things I want to
talk about because I know they
released it at Google IO is the
new style API that they're
going to do.
We will handle that in the
next rev of Arc2Earth.
Basically, anything
you can see.
You have your layers.
The renderers and labeling and
symbols will be able to, as
best as possible, get it
up into Fusion Tables.
You can define your info windows
directly inside of
ArcMap and have them show right
up in Fusion Tables.
So basically, the stuff I want
to show, the two quick demos,
is how can we make Fusion Tables
more GIS like and how
can we make them interoperate
with your
standard Enterprise GIS?
With Fusion Tables, you're
getting definitely
scaleability, zero
configuration, zero
maintenance for it.
So for a lot of our clients,
it's just a no-brainer to move
to this type of setup.
So the last point there is
probably the most important.
What we want to do is how do we
take Fusion Tables and then
make it look like something that
a typical ArcGIS server
can interoperate with?
And Esri, they released an open
REST specification that
then we took and implemented
up on top of AppEngine.
So some of the technology stacks
that we're using for
these demos is obviously
Google Maps Premier.
We have AppEngine,
Fusion Tables,
some ArcGIS and Arc2Cloud.
And Arc2Cloud is--
basically what we have running
up on top of AppEngine is a
wrapper around Fusion Tables,
and we're adding extra GIS
functionality to it.
Primarily what you want to look
at is the data sources up
top, and they are one for one
with your Fusion Tables.
We use [? Aloft ?]
to communicate with Fusion
Tables and then find out what
your data is and then add this
extra functionality.
We have a native REST API and
the geospatial REST spec is
how we interoperate with
Esri products.
One of the primary things we
wanted to be able to do was
every row of data that you have
inside of Fusion Tables,
we wanted to make it URL
addressable so that you can
get at it and have different
formats for it.
So every one of your rows and
every one of your searches you
can return as JSON, GeoJSON,
Esri's JSON specification.
Some of the lesser-known ones in
the GIS world are like GML,
well-known text.
You can get QR codes that are
associated with it and that
point back directly
at that data.
So basically, we are wrapping
Fusion Tables and getting it
more GIS like.
So for the quick demo, I just
wanted to be able to show you,
this is Arc2Cloud
user interface.
We're able to--
via your settings, you go in
and set up your [? Aloft ?]
tokens.
We can do this automatically for
you and that's how we tie
into your data.
And then you can start
building maps.
And maps are basically
collections of layers.
So we'll drill into this.
I've been downloading
it all day.
It has a list of layers.
You can see each one of these
is pointing directly at a
Fusion Table.
A bunch of polygons.
We've been doing demos in
the sandbox all day.
So that's cool.
So we're able to make a
collection of layers, and how
can we display this inside some
of the ESRI properties?
So let's take that same map
and we'll view it in
arcgis.com.
And so right now the arcgis.com
JavaScript is
talking to AppEngine and
AppEngine is talking to Fusion
Tables to get that data out, and
we can go in and use some
of their great editing tools
that are inside there.
Let's just draw a polygon out
in the middle of the ocean.
We can go in and change
attributes.
You can then attach photos and
stuff, and those photos will
be stored in AppEngine
in the BlobStore.
And the cool part obviously is
if we go back and take a look
at that same Fusion Table,
we'll see that it
automatically linked up, and
it's all ready to go for
everyone else to--
so there's that polygon.
So the idea is we have this
thing running on AppEngine
that's a wrapper around F
Fusion Tables and we're
synchronizing all the
data back and forth.
Any ArcGIS property can then
talk to it and then talk
directly to the Fusion Tables.
So another demo I wanted to
show real quickly was Task
Queue Geoprocessing.
We wanted to be able to use
the Google AppEngine Task
Queue to perform some of the
standard geospatial operations
on two or more Fusion Tables
at the same time.
This is usually something
you want to desktop.
Josh was showing you before how
something like the Earth
Engine works on raster data.
This is for vector data
in Fusion Tables.
It's kind of experimental now,
but we think it has a lot of
legs and something we're
going to be working on.
Some of the types of operations
you want to do is
full-layer buffering or
clipping, merging between two
different layers and coming up
with a new Fusion Table.
We're using JTS, Java Topology
Suite, and that's running up
on top of AppEngine.
So basically how this
would work is--
well, the top request
comes in.
It will go to the data store
iterator, and basically what
that is is how do you break
up processing this in a
map-produced type way?
Depending on the spatial
operation you're doing, you
may want to do it in ranges,
which is just groups of rows
from Fusion Tables, or if they
need to be spatially related,
it needs to be done in grids.
And grids will basically then go
out, query both the tables,
bring them back to AppEngine,
do the operation, and then
write it back out to
Fusion Tables.
So you can see on the right hand
of the screen there, you
can see that occurring in the
Task Queue, and then when it's
done, it's actually writing back
to the new Fusion Table.
So I'll just try and do a quick
demo of this to show you
what we're talking about.
So basically you go down to
your Analytics section.
We're going to do
a spatial join.
And what a spatial join is we
have two different tables, a
polygon table in Fusion
Tables and a point
layer in Fusion Tables.
We want to be able to add a
new field on the polygon
layer, and then sum up the count
of one of the properties
on the point layer.
Blockpop is the point layer.
We'll call this zipcode_join_9.
These are the different options
for the type of join
we want to do.
Here are the fields.
We want to calculate the total
number of households.
The aggregate operation is
how you want that to
actually be summed up.
A simple sum is fine.
And then we hit run.
And what this is doing now,
well, we saw in the last slide
is it's breaking up into
multiple ranges.
It's going off to the
Fusion Tables.
It's pulling that data in
and actually making
the join for you.
And so we saw a small error
there, but for the most part,
we'll be able to drill
in and see.
[TYPING]
BRIAN FLOOD: So if we look at
this new Fusion Table that was
created, we'll see there's now
a households field at the end
that's populated with the
sum of all that point
data that came in.
So the idea there is how can
we bring the standard
geospatial operations that you
do in the Esri and ArcGIS
world and bring it online and
do it inside the cloud?
So here are just some of the
pros and cons of this.
Distributed dataset analysis
is far more attractive.
You can do it on your live
data up in Fusion Tables.
The Fusion Table is immediately
available for your
online applications to use.
A lot of the stuff in the Task
Queue for AppEngine can take
care of small errors
and re-queue them.
Obviously, there's a lot
of bandwidth consumed.
We think in the future that this
is not going to be that
big a deal.
It might be now.
And then there's some
other issues with
oversampling of data.
On Arc2Cloud, we do have a
feature cache, which helps
with this type of operation.
So that's just my quick demo.
Thanks a lot for listening, and
come check us out in the
sandbox if you want to learn
a little bit more.
[APPLAUSE]
MANO MARKS: Thanks
a lot, Brian.
That's pretty impressive
stuff.
BRIAN FLOOD: Cool.
JOSH LIVNI: So just summing up
here, you can see a lot of
different ways that we can
overlap with the sort of
traditional GIS with a lot of
the services that we have and
look forward to some Q&A here.
If you don't mind just coming up
to the mikes and lining up
behind them, we'll
do our best.
MANO MARKS: Yes.
And also you'll see there's
a feedback link on there.
We're on the speaker meter, so
please feel free to give us
feedback on the talk.
Please come up to the mikes
if you have any questions.
Don't be shy.
AUDIENCE: A dumb question.
What's the price and model
for Fusion Tables?
MANO MARKS: So currently,
your--
any Google account gets
a free quota.
That's 250 megabytes.
If you get Maps API Premier,
then you get along with that I
believe it's 10 gigabytes;
is that right?
And then you can pay for
more by gigabyte.
JOSH LIVNI: We're just starting
to add some pricing
to Fusion Tables Premier, and
if you're already a Premier
customer, it would probably
be best just to
call the sales rep.
I'm not sure the numbers off the
top of my head, but we do
have a pricing model that gets
you additional QPS and
additional storage.
I'm not sure exactly
what it is offhand.
AUDIENCE: So one is a storage
and the other one is a hit?
MANO MARKS: So there's both.
So with the free Fusion Tables,
with your regular
Google account, you get five
queries per second and 250
megabytes of storage.
JOSH LIVNI: And to clarify,
that's against the API, not
views of people hitting
your stuff.
AUDIENCE: Right.
OK, yeah.
MANO MARKS: And then you get
much more with Premier.
And you can pay for
additional.
AUDIENCE: When would be the
final pricing coming out?
Do you guys--
MANO MARKS: The final pricing
is actually out, but you
should talk to a salesperson
about it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
All right, thanks.
MANO MARKS: Did you
have a question?
AUDIENCE: Well, I just had a
comment, that maybe I haven't
found it and you guys are
already on it, but you were
talking about getting
historical
data into Google Earth.
And one of the sites I've had
a lot of fun with is a place
called historicaerials.com, and
they have put online a lot
of the USGS aerial mappings
from the '40s, '50s
and '60s in the US.
MANO MARKS: Yeah, that's
a great site.
We're definitely aware
of that site.
So what you're asking
about is--
I have to repeat this
for the video--
is historical imagery and I
guess whether we can integrate
with stuff from Historical
Aerials.
Yeah, we are actively pursuing
additional historical imagery.
So if you go to Google Earth,
you can see there's a historic
imagery button, and there you
can view lot of different
imagery for different
locations.
Obviously, over the years,
we've built up our own
imagery, but we have imagery
going back I think into the
'30s, maybe even earlier than
that, so aerial imagery
obviously, satellite imagery
from the 1930s.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Well, I'll go look some more.
MANO MARKS: And that's also--
in November, I believe, we made
that available in the
Google Earth API so you can
programmatically interact with
that as well.
AUDIENCE: Nice.
Thanks.
MANO MARKS: Sure.
AUDIENCE: You showed the
distance-based queries on the
Fusion Table.
Is it just Euclidean and are
there are any plans for
network distance?
JOSH LIVNI: There aren't any
plans for network distance as
far as I know.
I should caveat that a little
bit with saying that the Maps
API, we just recently launched
a distance matrix calculation
that lets you do--
given a set of points, kind of
a matrix on them, you can get
the time it would take to travel
using various different
bicycling, walking and
driving directions.
So that type of network distance
we offer in the Maps
API using their sort
of directions API.
But Fusion Tables uses--
I don't think it's actually
Euclidean distance.
It's--
I'm not actually sure.
I should check up on that before
I say something it
might not be.
But yeah, we're probably not
going to offer network
distance in that.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned when you
upload data to the Fusion
Tables, if you include
additional information, that
may get geocoded.
Are there limits in the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
Not the fact that it's going
to get geocoded.
Like if I want to display-- if
I want to upload like a real
large data set.
MANO MARKS: Yeah, so the
limits are the same as
for the Maps API.
So you actually have to trigger
this in Fusion Tables,
when you upload a file and it's
got a single column for
your addresses.
And then you go into Maps, it'll
start to geocode it.
And the limit is 2,500 a day for
the free accounts and then
whatever your quotas
are for Premier.
AUDIENCE: So the geocoder is
about the same speed as if
you're using Google
Maps to geocode?
MANO MARKS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Good.
OK.
MANO MARKS: You don't need the
geocoder if you already have
latitude/longitude
information.
Next?
AUDIENCE: This question's
for Brian.
You mentioned how your products
can take the Google
content and stream it
into the ArcGIS.
BRIAN FLOOD: Right, right.
AUDIENCE: Is it the desktop?
BRIAN FLOOD: The desktop.
AUDIENCE: Can you elaborate on
that, how it works exactly?
BRIAN FLOOD: Well, basically, we
became an OEM partner with
Google so we were allowed
to do that.
And what it's doing in the
background is interacting with
the Google Maps Premier API.
And as you pan around on the
map, it's bringing the data in
and just displaying it
as an extra layer.
AUDIENCE: So it's using
the actual tiles.
It's not like a WMS
or something?
BRIAN FLOOD: It's not a WMS and
it's not the actual tiles.
It's kind of some secret sauce
that allows us to get the best
of both worlds.
AUDIENCE: OK.
BRIAN FLOOD: Some caching, but
doing it the legal, legit way
with Google.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: With Fusion Tables,
there is a final KML URL that
you can use, right?
MANO MARKS: That's correct.
AUDIENCE: So you can open up
KMLs in ArcGIS, can't you?
Or I guess you would just
get a snapshot.
If there's editing going on the
Fusion Table, you would
just get a snapshot in ArcGIS.
Job
MANO MARKS: So the question
is can you open up
KMLs directly in ArcGIS?
And yes, you can.
What you're getting out of
Fusion Tables is not--
you're not interacting
with a live KML file.
You're downloading.
Yeah, so you're right.
It's either a snapshot or a
network link which would
update periodically.
I'm not sure about ArcGIS
support for network links.
BRIAN FLOOD: I don't
think it has it.
MANO MARKS: I don't
Mike?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, this
isn't a question.
It's more of a paid
advertisement.
I work for the Enterprise team
on Geo, so if you want to buy
the Premier API or that portable
server or anything, I
can probably hook you up with
the right account rep.
So I'll hang out in the
back of the room.
If you want to get any more
information about pricing or
what we actually sell,
I'll sit in the back.
MANO MARKS: Great.
Thanks, Mike.
Any other questions?
All right.
Well, thanks for coming to
Google IO, everyone.
[APPLAUSE]
MANO MARKS: I hope you've
had a great time.
I certainly have. Josh, Brian
and I are going to be hanging
out for a little while
afterwards.
So if you have any--
you want to come up and
ask us directly.
Thanks a lot, everyone.
JOSH LIVNI: Thank you.